[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
millionaire real estate air robert durst
hospitalized in the middle of his trial
testimony is on hold for now he was down
he was not in his
chair an idaho man gets life in prison
for the 1996 rape and killing
of an 18 year old how dna evidence
caught the real killer
and freed the wrong man in prison for 20
years whatever you give this man
is not enough plus is it alleged affair
and questions over paternity
motive for the killing of a
five-year-old boy what we know about the
trial of joseph ray daniels as
prosecutors rest their case
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the murder trial of robert durst is now
on pause as the real estate heir is
taken to the hospital
for an incident involving his health in
jail
what has happened is that mr gerst had a
health incident
this morning and is in the jail hospital
and so we cannot proceed without him
being here
according to the judge the 78 year old
defendant robert durst is in the
hospital
few details of the incident are known
but defense attorneys for durst have
previously said
he suffers from hydrocephalus bladder
cancer and chronic kidney disease
prosecutor john lewin told the judge he
is suspect as to what durr's actual
condition is
mr durst is on record in his
in his jail calls saying that he's going
to fake dementia
saying that he's going to secure a
mistrial due to covid
so i have no idea whether this is
legitimate or not
durst is accused of murdering his best
friend susan berman in december 2000
one of robert durr's friends was in the
middle of testifying as a hostile
witness for the state
doug oliver was ordered to return to the
stand on wednesday
mr oliver has played games with us from
the start
he's been rude he's been disrespectful
he's repeatedly lied
let me finish that's not a dream mr
garrett let me finish
the man literally said well i'm gonna go
to england and good luck finding me
and the drama in the trial continued
during oliver's testimony on wednesday
prosecutor lewin tried to ask oliver
about a comment oliver apparently said
to lewin
about kathy durst the defendant's
missing wife
does the concept mr oliver of kathy
durst being sold into white
slavery does that sound like something
that
you could have thought no i would never
have thought of that and i believe
so i want you to assume for a moment in
this hypothetical that you made that
comment
can you explain why you would have said
that that's assuming something
objection fall false statement okay
to all statements sorry objection i'm
sorry
my mouth got stuck in my
mouth
it's a hypothetical not based on a valid
basis
okay so what you are saying close enough
your honor yes as an offer of proof
detectives
[Music]
okay everybody inhale
shall we take a break now exhale
direct examination continued as the
prosecution asked more about cathy's
disappearance and well
it didn't exactly go according to plan
i asked you a simple question you didn't
answer it then you said you needed to
write
approximately an eight question eight
word question down
which you then wrote you can hear you
writing on it
does that make sense to you that you
would need to write down that question
to be able to answer it it made sense to
me
you didn't want to answer the question
though did you i didn't want to answer
any of your questions
what subjects you talked about with bob
durst
in the immediate aftermath of his wife's
disappearance
any of those calls yes i don't recall
the cause at all in the last in the last
four years have you had a conversation
with mr durst about what happened to his
wife kathy
no i don't believe we have why
because he's in jail joining us today is
criminal defense attorney adam conta
and terry austin adam durst is now
hospitalized but the lawyers seem to be
planning to call witnesses
next week what do you make of that well
obviously health issues are very
private and so the judge can only say so
much but you could tell by his demeanor
that this isn't a serious incident
i've had trials while elderly elderly
gentlemen fell out of a wheelchair
the jail cell the jailed facility has to
send them to the hospital
uh so assuming it's something minor like
that it's probably just a routine trip
to the hospital
he'll be back tonight or tomorrow
morning and ready to go for monday
makes sense terry sparks continue to fly
in this case oliver was on the stand
before we learned of durst being sent to
the hospital how'd the lawyers handle
the rescheduling of witnesses in that
testimony
you know there were so many sparks going
on and you saw there that the judge had
to tell everyone to take a deep breath
and this all started just because they
were trying to reschedule oliver
and when oliver started to begin to talk
about he wanted to come later because
his mother was
ill we heard lewin say that he did not
trust oliver and we also heard lewin say
that he didn't trust durst meaning that
perhaps durst was faking everything i
will say though
brian that when oliver first got on the
stand
we saw durst he actually waved at oliver
as if to say hello i haven't seen you in
a while great that you're here
and he fist pumped him at one point as
if to say
good job thanks for coming here for me
so i think this has been one of the most
interesting witnesses and clearly the
most
hostile witness yeah absolutely a fist
bump to that congratulations adam i
think if robert durst had the choice
he'd probably be fist bumping him like
this right like a little good job there
yeah like one of those so i'm not sure
how the journey is going to interpret
that but
we'll keep our eyes on this case thank
you both still ahead on law and crime
daily both sides rest in the trial of a
father accused
of murdering his five-year-old son but
first sentencing for the cold case rape
and murder of an 18 year old girl
the strong words from the victim's
mother next
[Music]
welcome back 25 years after an 18 year
old was raped and murdered in her own
apartment
her convicted killer is now sentenced to
spend the rest of his life
in prison and i can't forgive you
ever carol dodge addressed her
daughter's killer for a final time in
court
you have shattered our family
it may have been broken before it
happened but it is literally
shattered and there is no way to pick up
the pieces
ever again brian drips pled guilty to
raping and murdering the 18 year old
angie dodge in her idaho falls apartment
in june 1996.
as part of the deal he was sentenced to
life in prison with the possibility of
parole
after 20 years i'm sorry
i did intend for this to
happy for more than two decades police
thought they had caught the killer
then 20 year old christopher tapp
confessed and was sentenced to life in
prison
but dna at the scene excluded tap and he
said he had been
coerced angie's mother carol teamed up
with the innocent project
urging investigators to take another
look at the case tap was released in
2017 and exonerated in 2019.
genetic genealogy was then used to match
drip's dna
to semen found on the victim he lived
every day of those 23 years
as though another man was not sitting in
prison for his crimes
for 20 of those years and mr drips told
investigators
that he had seen videos about angie's
murder he knew
someone was serving time for his crime
and yet every day he woke up and refused
to take accountability
for his actions angie died from multiple
incision wounds to her neck and torso
her throat was cut her head nearly
decapitated
drips lived across the street from her
and was questioned at the time of the
murder
he said he had been so drunk and high on
cocaine he hadn't seen anything happen
decades later drips admitted to breaking
into the victim's apartment with the
intent to rape her
then took out a knife and stabbed her in
fact mr drips told investigators
that he believed angie was still alive
when he left
now if we were to believe that statement
this means that mr drips
made the conscious decision to leave
angie
without calling for help knowing that
she was grievously injured
knowing that she was suffering knowing
that she very probably would die alone
in her bedroom defense attorneys for
drip says the 55 year old is sick and is
almost certain to die
before he can ever be released from
prison drifts maintains he doesn't
remember
much of the night of the murder and
apologize to the dodge family
for carol dodge those words will never
be enough
you brian drips do you deserve eternal
hell
back with us as criminal defense
attorney adam conte and terry austin
terry the absolute strength of this
mother to be told a person killed your
daughter
then to tell them they have the wrong
person and now she's finally seen the
right man sentence
what did you make of her final words you
know what brian she had strength and she
also had perseverance as a mother it's
really hard to listen to this
you know she said to her daughter i love
you those were apparently the last words
she said to her this was a brutal
senseless and heartless murder this
child was only 18 years old and she died
in her
own apartment that's horrible when you
think that this is somewhere you're
supposed to be
safe the one good thing is now obviously
they have the right man behind
bars but the wrong man spent decades
behind bars so
that's not good i also think thank
goodness for the innocence project
because they persevered as well yeah
adam let's kind of talk about that
people are rightfully angry that drip
didn't come forward as you heard there
but
he didn't convict tap what about the
judges the prosecutors and the officers
who clearly got it wrong here
yeah i mean this is a really good
example of something that is becoming
more and more commonplace in the in the
public sort of
uh culture and that's that false
confessions are a very
real thing that the way that police
investigate people is to beat them down
until they feel like they have no other
options until confessing sometimes it
works and it's true
but sometimes it doesn't the fact that
this man spent 20 years in jail
obviously with no physical evidence
connecting him to this crime
everyone's on the hook for this the
prosecutor number one
the prosecutor number one the police
number two and then you know so on and
so forth but
nothing nothing will replace this man's
two decades spent behind bars
for a crime he didn't commit no matter
what ultimate million dollar
multi-million dollar settlement
he gets he would trade that in a second
to have those 20 years back
yeah on one side we've got to look at
the justice part
from where the right person is serving
time but on the other side how do we
make sure that no one's spending
over two decades in jail for a crime
they never committed thank you both
on this at brian tripp's case coming up
on law and crime daily
a father on trial for murder decides not
to take the stand in his own defense
plus arizona officers fight off an
inmate accused of attacking them
and taking them to the ground the latest
on a e's court cam
you don't want to miss
welcome back an arizona man is accused
of choking officers
using their own handcuffs lawn crime
founder dan abrams is here with a
shocking video
on his a e show court cam
you're gonna go to the hospital if you
resist any okay i know i already know
okay i've done it before you know mama
you've seen my record no i haven't
well i hope you don't see it court
documents show lions was previously
convicted of assaulting officers
this time they make absolutely sure
they've secured the cuffs
behind his back they're dope
they're they are pretty good
[Applause]
lions may be contained but that doesn't
mean he's gonna go quiet okay
okay
that's what it is lions is led back to
his cell
where he continues to mouth off at the
male officer
okay that's messed up
lyons is booked into maricopa county
jail and now faces two additional
aggravated assault charges against a
correction officer
when we come back the final testimony in
the trial of a father who confessed the
to the killing of his son
then recanted the shocking messages and
searches next
welcome back sexually explicit text
message may explain a motive for a
tennessee father on trial
for allegedly killing his five-year-old
autistic son
prosecutors say joseph ray daniels
murdered his son joseph clyde daniels in
april 2018
then disposed of his body daniels
confessed but has since recanted
investigators obtained facebook records
from daniel's wife crystal and another
man
the record appears to show crystal
daniels in an affair and her intention
to leave daniels for the other man
if i was your wife would you allow for
that to go on question mark
the next crystal daniel's on the same
day if i tell
you anything i ripped up our marriage
license and i went and had the papers
drawn up all that has to be done as
is him sign them and then the papers
have to be followed with the court
crystal daniels the same day i haven't
been happy for the last three years
crystal daniels and i have to say i
think i started falling for you because
you treated me with respect
and you treated me like a person as well
as you treated me like a woman
thomas richards i think getting your own
place would help
crystal daniels he will never leave his
daddy
crystal daniels but i have already
filled out a housing
and section 8 application for me and my
babies
and with all three boys in school next
year will be easy for me to work while
they are in school
so i can pay my bills and give them a
good life crystal danish
and we get twelve hundred dollars a
month on baby joe because of his
disability
investigators also say they found google
search records on the defendant's phone
from three days before the victim went
missing looking up anonymous paternity
tests
genovate.com and what is the genovate
website
dna paternity test and what's the time
this was visited
last visited 3 30 2018 at 11 51 p.m
march 30th 2018 11 52 pm visit website
dnatesting.com
with the question about testing without
mom or dad
and what does the extract reveal from
this web search
web history the title is how can i do a
secret paternity test without mom dad or
child knowing
march 31 2018
1206 am from the defendant's phone was a
text message sentence yes
it was sent to his mother and what does
this text message
say it says this world
by the time you see this message i'll be
six feet under
in the instruction what is the assumed
message
it's showing the text message
331 2018 at 1206 a.m
parties yes the parties is mom which is
april all right adam and terry let's
break this down adam does the motive the
prosecution is putting forward
sway you in any way or are there some
holes in it
no i this motive doesn't really sway me
at all um
i mean the case in and of itself is very
strong
someone in that house killed that little
boy tragically
and it sure seems like the dad did and
the brother testifying the other day
really makes it seem like you did so i
think they have enough already
i mean the prosecutor doesn't have to
have just one motive obviously
but this particular edition of an affair
if anything it muddies the water a
little bit
um and maybe puts a little blame on her
that she kind of
maybe wanted out i i don't know i don't
think they needed it i don't think it
made the case any stronger
but i think it's a really strong case
without
agree now terry considering all of that
was it a smart move for the defense
not to put on a case you know what i
think it was a very
smart move he didn't need to put on a
case he did a great job cross-examining
as annoying and as abrasive as he was
and he really was i think lockhart the
defense attorney
did an excellent job on cross-examining
all of the prosecution witnesses his
main defense and his main point was that
the
authorities did not investigate
thoroughly they did not follow
all of the leads and while i think that
the
evidence showed that the authorities did
investigate thoroughly
there was some doubt that the defense
raised and
if he raises doubt in just one
individual
that could avoid as you know a unanimous
guilty verdict and that's
really all he needs to do absolutely
now the next step for them is there
going to be some
closing arguments some arguments as to
the charges and then
the jury will get the case make sure you
check out law and crime network for
gavel to gavel
on that case uh terry any expectation as
to what you may see in this closing
arguments that may
really push this case one way or another
well i think the prosecution is going to
tie
everything together the defense is going
to say there's just not enough
and i think we're going to see at the
end of the day a guilty verdict
all right adam terry thank you and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you